[Music]
[Applause]
so is Chris Sims he's not afraid to hurt
your feelings pro football talk live
co-host and contributor to football
night America former NFL quarterback and
we have the 2023 Sims top 40 quarterback
countdown that we'll get to coming up in
a moment
help me understand what happened in
Buffalo
and is there another shoe to drop here
everything okay in Buffalo with Stefan
Diggs and Josh Allen well I think we're
all going to have our antennas up here
right I do think things are okay yes but
I mean we know they're a team that's in
the Super Bowl window it's one of the
best combinations in football Alan the
Diggs so I think all of us were you know
maybe not so I wasn't surprised I think
we all knew maybe something in there
with Stefan Diggs too it got to the
point that it got to on Tuesday I think
that was a little shocking you know by
talking to some people and having a
little feel you know I don't know the
full story but it seems like it's a it's
it's a number of things it's not just
one thing there right you know whether
it's you know a little bit more money uh
wanting the ball more wanting better
results from the team wanting the ball
more in in big situations you know I
could kind of see all of that being part
of this stew of issues that you know
Stefan Diggs has right uh obviously
there was a some sort of a argument or a
blowout on Tuesday McDermott said they
needed some space so that's why he went
home you know so that obviously wasn't a
a great conversation there right but I
think we're all going to be looking at
it now because yeah is this going to
become a distraction uh and and I'm
surprised it got to this point and I
think that's what Josh Allen was trying
to say on Tuesday too you know they got
to be better he's got to be better
calling and reaching out the
organization you know I don't know what
he was trying to say maybe they got to
be better in letting stuff on Diggs know
how important he is to them and how much
they love him that seems like a bunch of
that stuff's going on and yeah I just
hope it doesn't make it a distraction
for this football team because I like
watching them and I like watching digs
and Allen
wide receivers as rookies it used to be
they didn't contribute it was really
difficult to make that transition we're
seeing receivers young receivers making
an impact
um why is why have things changed where
you're drafting a receiver you expect
your receiver to be a major contributor
yeah yeah no I think it's a little bit
Dan and I think we've had this
conversation in the past a little bit
about the quarterbacks right because
that expectation level has gone way up
too for even rookie quarterbacks we we
know they're going to go through
struggles but hey we almost expect all
of them to be able to play and do
something positive right where I think
it's a little bit of the the culture in
our country and where football is right
now just with how much you know it's
it's sixth grade my son's in sixth grade
seventh grade there's flag football all
year round kids are getting to run
around catch the ball you get to high
school high school teams are throwing
the ball 40 times a game you know
they're playing seven on seven and stuff
like like that in the off season and
then the same with college to where I
just feel like they're more adapted and
ready to go in the past game maybe than
what they used to be in the old days
where you came out of college and they
were like you know we just had a basic
pass offense and oh we get to the NFL
whoa there's a lot to learn here it's
it's you know colleges are pretty you
know a lot more advanced than what they
ask receivers to do now than maybe they
did 15 20 30 years ago yeah I brought up
that I think Zay flowers has a chance to
be really special with Baltimore I think
he's right really talented even though
he came out of BC and we're like Boston
College with him right right and then
you know Odell Beckham is the old guy
now at age 30 I'm just curious
those injuries and the way he played
like what would be the expectation level
for you if you're John Harbaugh or Lamar
Jackson for Odell Beckham this year I I
mean I I don't think it's fair to say
like I I I'm I'm a huge Odell Beckham Jr
fan and I know he's got the injuries but
do I think he can get a thousand yards
receiving absolutely right okay I I do
you know not to say that it's just going
to be easy you know like a walk in the
street no I don't think he's going to be
like leading the league in receiving
yards like a Jamar Chase or Justin
Jefferson or a Tyree kill but you know
do I think like his his ultimate
potential could lead him to being oh
wait oh hey he's the go-to guy he's the
guy they throw two on Third and eight
and he's leading the team and receiving
yards I certainly think that's there you
know I don't expect them to quite be as
explosive as he was but we're talking
about a guy that was like as explosive
as we've ever seen so and I know it's
two ACLS but I still think you're gonna
see someone that can run by people and
make some things have happen after the
catch I hope so uh yeah I hope so too
yeah we had a social media exchange last
year late in the season when everybody
was talking about him going to the
Cowboys and I said has anybody asked the
question can he even play now and he
called me an outsider and uh
basically saying you know what I I
didn't know anything well I did know
because he didn't play and nobody asked
that questions like everybody wanted to
sign him I said can he play and you know
we found out that he couldn't play all
right you have your list here The Sims
top 40 quarterback countdown right you
got different categories here
yeah we made some things you know I make
the list and then as we get ready to do
a certain show on the podcast where we
might be releasing five or six we tried
to come up with something creative to
explain that tier right and that just
was something that I think held or
helped out on social media a little bit
all right so Patrick Mahomes Joe burrow
Josh Allen your top three then Justin
Herbert yep right right
Lamar Jackson Trevor Lawrence Jalen
hurts Aaron Rodgers is eight the Sean
Watson nine Matthew Stafford who you
have a man crush on is 10. okay
um all right so what do you want to ask
me first what do you what do you think
um I'm trying to figure out is Jalen
hurts great
or is he on a great team right I think
that's what I'm trying to figure out too
you know I got to keep in mind they were
gonna use their two first round picks if
they had to to move up in this draft if
Jalen hurts didn't work out there was a
report that Russell Wilson turned down
coming to the Eagles yes they weren't
sold on Jalen hurts Jalen heard surprise
the Eagles exactly that's where I you
know I my job is like I I want to say
all those things you said sometimes for
all the people that hate on me and or
whatever get mad about my My Views there
and I want to be like wait the team
that's employing them was also trying to
trade for DeSean Watson too and got
involved in that as well yeah right so
yeah there there's he he's really damn
good things are going in the upward
trajectory we know that he's I think one
of the top leaders in football which I
take into account the teams will leave
your ability to take the team through
some tough times and all of that right
but I think your question is real he did
improve was a passer he he makes a one
thing when I watch him watch him he is a
machine and he makes the right play and
the right decision time after time after
time but to your big question there yes
I question that and I do still think
there's room there that has to be
improved you know he's for NFL starting
quarterback standards he's a little bit
above average as far as a thrower a
passer his arm in the NFL and I know the
Super Bowl was really good it was really
good but it's not as good as what people
think and I think to me that was a
little bit of the microcosm was still
the issue or the thing I'd like to see
Jalen hurts get better I know he threw
for 350 yards I get that but the Chiefs
played a defense that whole game that
was like sell out to stop the run I mean
I laughed watching the film in that game
because I was like man Steve Spagnola
must be on the sideline going I can't
believe I'm calling this defense on the
37-yard line on second and nine and I'm
gonna Blitz everybody to stop the run
game and leave AJ Brown and Devonte
Smith with no help and just leave him on
an island and to me that's the area
where hurt still has to improve because
what I would say is the quarterback's in
front of him that the Chiefs defense
would not be able to play that style
against them Trevor Lawrence some of
those other quarterbacks in front of
them Herbert Burrough mums they would
have thrown for 500 yards if they were
played that way and that's to me where
there has to be a more of an improvement
you think about big moments during the
year for the eagles they usually relied
on the Run game more than the pass
needed a must-win drive against the
Colts to win the game they ran the ball
all the way down the field the Cowboys
and the first Sunday night game early in
the year game got close they went we're
going to run the ball every play so uh I
have the same thought you do I see a lot
of positive things he certainly proved
me wrong but I still have a few more
questions
all right your next 10 Daniel John
Daniel Jones 11th Kirk Cousins Dak
Prescott 13 Russell Wilson Geno Smith
Ryan Tannehill Jared Goff Derek Carr
Kyler Murray is 19 Mac Jones is 20. all
right help me understand Daniel Jones
here well Daniel Jones I mean like you
know you've heard me talk about this
before right I mean all
little support or something and I'm big
into watching the game and going you
know what was there to be had right
you've heard me say this before and you
know what did you what did you make out
of it right and and I'm not one like
some of these grading companies that
goes oh they got a five-yard completion
ooh positive grade I sometimes see the
five-year completion go wait there's a
guy screaming open down the middle for a
40-yard gain that was that yeah you can
give them a nice little okay good job
getting the completion but we just left
the touchdown on the board or a 50-yard
completion on the board or I'm big into
Wait nothing is there there's nobody
open the protection's not that great and
they're still getting positive yards and
when I watch Daniel Jones I he made the
offense go this year you know I mean
most people can't name receivers on the
Giants that's true if they were open by
half an inch he hit him but he's not
even the most valuable player on his on
his side of the ball
well yeah I mean I know your saquon
Barkley's more sexy I think he is more
valuable I don't think the Giants could
have done what they did last year
without Daniel Jones his ability to
throw the ball with people around him in
the pocket where they still weren't a
good offensive line and still throw the
ball and put it on the money and then
Dan I think the other thing too is his
running ability is what opened up the
offense for everything because you got
to worry he's he's one of the best
quarterback runners in football you know
after Lamar Jackson Justin Fields is
Jalen hurts I would argue Daniel Jones
and Josh Allen are the next next guys in
line that you'd go are the best running
quarterbacks in football and there's so
many scrambles and runs where you go
nobody's open and they didn't protect
but he scrambled and ran for 15. so
that's where I give him Great Value he
still doesn't have great support around
it but you saw for the first time in his
career he had some semblance of an
offense and some semblance of past
protection and they go to the playoffs
and he did really damn good and I think
took advantage of all that was there to
be had so that's where I liked what I
saw from Daniel Jones no you got a group
here of you say uh bleep or get off the
pot yeah Jimmy Garoppolo Justin Fields
Baker Mayfield Junior III yeah yeah I
it's going to be hard for Tua to not be
really good this year yeah I think two
is if he's healthy if you said he plays
17 games this year I think he's gonna
put up really impressive numbers I I
don't know why do you have him 21st
well because like you just said if he's
healthy you just put up numbers and I
want to go well yeah there's like
everybody in the top 20 we put him on
the Dolphins they're going to be if they
can stay healthy they're going to put up
numbers right and that's where I need to
see more from Tua too you know again the
game was made easy there's there's a
reason we heard teams play against the
Dolphins last year and go oh you know
one yard pass one yard pass fake the one
yard pass Tyreek Hill is open for a
50-yard bomb you know I mean the game
was a little bit easy that way then we
saw some games or oh wait they got a
defensive game plan and they couldn't do
anything so you think he's gonna put up
really good numbers he's just not a
really good quarterback well I I just
would like to see more I need to see a
little bit more of like the Chargers
game or the 49ers game where some of the
easy plays were taken away and now you
got to start making some more high level
throws and quarterback plays and he
didn't do that in those games so that's
where you know I'm still think he's very
dependent on the system home and the
players around him and I know everybody
needs that too okay with that yeah but
yeah but so that's I just need to see a
little bit more but certainly on the
upward trajectory he is quick as hell
he's got a quick release you know he's
got great touch and timing and a lot of
throws
um but yeah then the health thing that
you brought up too that that plays into
this discussion too and where he's
ranked a little bit I look at this as my
quarterback depth chart you know I'm not
going to put a guy that I feel like is
the most injury prone guy on the list
and go well I think I want to bring him
off the bench first here basically right
you know so there's things I I worry
about there and still just need to see a
little Improvement well you definitely
need to see more from Brock Purdy you
have him 26th on the list
um Jordan love it 31.
yeah yeah I I like Jordan Love's Talent
you know I I've liked what I saw in the
preseason he has skilled position
players with him he's got he does
running backs right on some wide
receivers yeah I hear you there and you
know that's where this drill this drills
hard I try to take away the team right
we're all playing on the same team I
tried not to but like would the Packers
shock me if they were in the playoffs
this year absolutely not that would they
shock you if they don't make the plans
not shocking I think I would be shocked
if I was like they don't even come close
to making the playoffs so they're not
even the conversation right but I would
I expect them to be in the conversation
and I think you know they're all the
lines good you know the running backs
the receivers like you said the defense
underperformed last year and still was a
top 12 defense in the in the game you
know I like his skills I just got to see
more and see him play but he did give me
some confidence about what he did last
year when he did get to play against the
Eagles and a little bit other times in
the preseason
do you love Matthew Stafford don't you
well well let's uh let's talk about that
just for a second because it says you
brought it up twice
because you know again let's let's not
this is not just all about last year
right you know I have to I have to
factor in last year no no I know and I
do too I'm with you too and I it's a
fair question that's where that's where
I love you and I'm glad you are
factoring it in you're right but I I
also have to factor in the year before
that where he led the NFL in touchdowns
and probably could have been or should
have been the Super Bowl MVP right so
and then you know you take into account
I and one of the things I said when I
broke this down out of the quarterbacks
in the top 25 Matthew Stafford and
Russell Wilson had the worst past
protection out of anybody I mean they
had no chance Matthew Stafford in the
Buccaneers Cowboys 49ers game that was
Almost Human abuse I mean he would get
the ball and it was like Duck save
yourself do it I mean you don't have
time to look just throw it away and Duck
and Chuck man so they had drives and
points where I watched the game and go
oh my my gosh what a throw what a job in
the pocket way to be tough it's kind of
a gift and a curse there but yeah I'm a
little bit maybe more of a Believer
Matthew Stafford the most and I get that
okay yeah no worse yeah just turned it
up it's only June I appreciate that I'm
not trying to I'm just you know being me
but apparently being me stirs it up a
little bit every now and then thank you
Chris
thank you Dan tell the guys I said hi
what's up everybody guys Chris says hi
hi Chris
Christians NBC Sports and of course uh
co-host with uh Mike Florio pro football
talk we'll come back your phone calls
next